what do you think is the most important
question that humans can ask are we
alone that to me is the most important
question if we're not alone
then somebody else might have answers
to other let's say less
or more immediate existential
uh questions right that you know what
what can we do about this what can we do
about that or you know are there other
dimensions you could list a thousand
questions and you know if they would be
willing to give us the answers I mean
I've said this before I think we're just
a bunch of angry angry Apes I don't
think we're ready for uh some of the
answers yet and you know it's like you
don't tell your children certain things
until they're mature enough
and we've pretty much proven that we're
still not mature enough yet
[Music]
Gary Nolan on the show Gary is a
professor at Stanford of pathology he
studies biology and microbiology
um so he has a real background in
medicine and and anything that you think
of from a doctor's standpoint but he has
really gone out on a limb and
Incorporated
um
extraterrestrial craft and he's been
doing research on the materials
themselves and really just like feeding
that inner monologue of what are we here
for what are we and trying to get those
answers so we did talk about that of
course and we also talked about the
human body and what it is and what is
DNA and how does the body work and what
is its interaction with this world how
did it come about where is it going and
at what levels does it exist and so we
talked also about the theories of the
universe of holographic Universe
simulation Theory the Multiverse so this
is just this is the kind of conversation
like that I just want to have all day
every day where we are not sure about
anything and he makes that very clear
that these are all ifs these are all
just ideas and Concepts and asking
questions but it's but he also had a
great thought that maybe the question is
anchoring the answer in the universe and
so he explains what he means by that so
enjoy today's deeply fascinating episode
be sure to hit the Subscribe button I'd
love to hear what you have to say in the
comments let's get out there let's think
outside the box I can't wait to read
them we've got like you know a doctor
biology brain but then you also have
this other new interesting side of more
science and data and aliens and UFOs
which is of course fascinating so how
how did that end up happening I such a
it feels like there's a lot of
similarities but it is such a transition
to go from biology microbiology and
being in the lab like that to you know
testing
UFO materials well I mean I if you are a
biologist and I have both an undergrad
in genetics uh at Cornell and then I got
my PhD at Stanford in the department of
genetics
so you know you're naturally driven to
think about Evolution and where did we
come from
right and so when you start thinking
about the beginnings of Life on this
planet if you do any amount of reading
you come across the theory of panspermia
right and so panspermia basically
meaning the distribution of Life Across
the Universe by an initial seating that
happened somewhere and then it spread as
you know life does like mold even though
it spreads
um and so uh
there's lots of ideas about this people
don't have a sense of what life can do
um and if you look at
uh for instance where did all of the
material on this planet come from the
Rocks the metals
Etc it came from an exploding star
that became a gas which then eventually
coalesced into a you know into a sun and
planets
so that much time can go by between one
star's existence and its birth of
another star eventually
um but during that event you could
imagine the explosion sending rocks and
pieces of that original
solar system elsewhere and if there were
spores or things on that they could go
along for the ride
and so that's the concept of panspermia
that uh at the very least you can
imagine microbial life spreading and
then seeding life elsewhere
um now you know there's a different kind
of panspermia notion that you know if
a uh intelligent race was uh ever you
know happened you know several billions
of years ago it has more than enough
time to spread across
nearly the entire universe even just at
the speed of light
right
um and so you know it's just it it's not
many steps to thinking about that and
especially for someone like me I was
interested in science fiction as a kid
and so all of these Concepts were
already there
for me at least I mean as fiction
but then you know when you
as a scientist come across instances of
a question you might ask
rather than let's say being a member of
the lay public where it remains a
question you can be sure of what you
think the answer is but you know as a
scientist I have the means uh in my
laboratory to actually study it to
answer the question that's always how
I've been I've always been about okay
well I'm interested in this part of
biology how do I do it okay this is what
I would need to do to prove or disprove
this
and so I just bring the same
ethic the same approach to the you know
the alien problem or the non-human
intelligence problem uh in that you know
it's there's a lot of uh
let's say we would call in The Sciences
preliminary data
right there's a lot of preliminary data
that suggests many different hypotheses
so some of those hypotheses are testable
uh so let's do it so that's how I came
to it
okay so amazing and I have a lot of
those same questions so you talked about
you know microbial life kind of
spreading right it could be like a like
a mold but it just little spores and
little bits could be spread out what is
that when you say that microbial what is
what is it actually
so it would be
um those spores of bacteria for instance
right so there's plenty of spores on
Earth
of bacteria that can survive space and
hard radiation right bacillus there's a
number of bacillus strains that have
this ability
so you know it's if it's you know Frozen
and in vacuum and it could last an awful
long time and we already have instances
of bacteria and other living things you
know surviving hundreds of thousands of
years and then being Resurrected right
so it's you know it's it's not a big
difference between a hundred thousand
years and say 10 million or even a
billion years the time that it might
take to go from one place to another
um you know I mean imagine uh a large
chunk of rock like what Avi Loeb pointed
out the Uma event right uh going from
one solar system to another you know it
just takes a little bit of that over
time uh to spread out into many
different places uh around the Galaxy or
even around you know the universe let's
say yeah but there's some interesting
evidence for it uh and and uh one of
those bits of evidence is uh what's
called the Moore's Law of uh genetic
complexity you've all heard of Moore's
Law for semiconductors it's a you know
it's a made-up law but the idea is that
for whatever reason
um every I don't know what it is 10
years or five years whatever the number
is uh the complexity of computer chips
doubles
right and the speed doubles
um
and so we're always you'll see if you
read in the in computer magazines
there's this have we reached the end of
Laura's law you know and then somebody
discovers quantum computers right uh and
so then
Etc so you know it's it's more just an
observation of what happens so somebody
thought to look at the complexity of DNA
and the regulatory uh regions of DNA
that are in many ways like a computer
right these are the areas Upstream of
the regions of the genes that encode the
proteins the things that you know we are
and the enzymes that make us Etc there
are these regulatory regions which if
you're a computer scientist you would
look at it you would think of as the
is the actual code
um of what's of what is of how a person
is made
um okay and now the complexity of that
in let's say simple bacteria it's it's
it's extremely simple right they're they
don't have the kind of regulatory
phenomenon that that we have okay
um but if you think of bacteria as a
ancient uh example of what our great
great great great grandparents might
look like
right and then you look and you go up
the chain of
um Evolution from bacteria to eukaryotes
to multicellular things Etc up the chain
and you call those you call that
evolution
right that's all we really have to see
right now
um and then you look at and then you
basically say well bacteria evolved
I don't know uh two billion years ago
whatever the number is these are the
ones this so you create that timeline
and then you give some measure of
complexity
it turns out that the complexity
uh of when things actually
started was about 10 billion years ago
billion or million billion billion
billion okay but how long has Earth been
around
four billion years
right okay so there's a six billion year
Gap
um so basically there's two answers to
that
the first answer is it actually evolved
that long ago
right right six billion years ago or
something about Evolution took a fast
leap up
and then became the straight line yeah
I'm really curious about that up part so
so it's either if if life on Earth
happened and instantiated only four
billion years ago
fast leap up and then became this linear
curve
um and that's perfectly possible
um or you could say it started somewhere
else
and just traveled here right okay and so
um that's the first one I find that
interesting uh the second one is a paper
and and that actually is a paper and
then a peer-reviewed and there's another
peer-reviewed paper called the wow
signal in the genetic code by a couple
of mathematicians from I think
Uzbekistan
um and I don't pretend to understand the
math and I'm sure there's some
statisticians that would argue with it
but their concept was interesting the
um the actual what we call the genetic
code the the uh transfer rnas that
basically say you know Proline goes here
or leucine goes there that allow for the
proteins to be made
they are so well organized in terms of
the structure of the of who codes for
what
um that it looks like it was designed
right and then they go through some
mathematical models of why it had to
have been designed
and
you know there's some caveats that I'll
mention at the end here
uh that uh the chance of it not having
been designed is like one in several
hundred trillion right right and what
they're saying is the wow message so
you've heard of this thing called the
wow message that when somebody first
thought that they heard a radio signal
from another
civilization they said wow they wrote
wow on it and that became the wow signal
so they said look the signal is actually
in our DNA
the fact that that DNA was planned
and organized is right there in front of
us that's the wow signal huh now you
know there's
um
there's a guy who wrote uh a book called
The Selfish Gene
uh and
um his name is Richard Dawkins a famous
Professor genetics Professor from
England
who basically says look that's rubbish
not this wow signal itself
but you know the whole notion of divine
intervention or planned genetics the you
know the creationists it's rubbish
because there are other mathematical
principles that you can throw at this
that say that you don't need that you
know and and I think this guy is
fantastic right so his is a fantastic
counter argument
to the wow signal but it isn't the
disproof
right same saying that there is an
alternate explanation isn't proof of the
alternate explanation
right it's like that's the it's so it's
still in limbo
right as to what it whether this wow
signal is true or not even if it's not
true
the fact that the DNA code is so
organized in and of itself is beautiful
I mean as a scientist I I appreciate the
the beauty of that
right they it's so well organized and I
mean but we can look at any ecosystem
and say it's so well organized somebody
must have invented it no no you don't
have to invent it Richard Dawkins shows
how things can evolve so what about I
mean this makes me start thinking about
fractals and energy and patterns and
recurring patterns in nature and I mean
do you what about that what about just
patterns of energy showing up on a micro
and a macro level
what about that well I mean yeah so the
universe is organized with a pattern
right if you look right down at the laws
that we think are running the universe
all of these particles with features and
capabilities
uh how they will interact
um that allow for us
basically it says that embedded in the
structure of the universe is the
capability to produce us now the
question
the open question is did somebody create
the universe so that something like us
could
occur
right or is it just chance and we're
lucky
right so there's this concept in the
Multiverse ideas of that the in other
universes the laws of physics might be
different
right that if you take the various what
we call constants of physics Planck
constant Etc as all these you know
various numbers and you change them only
slightly
uh any one of them only slightly
suddenly you don't have a universe like
ours that could even have
protons right that it would basically
you you wouldn't get anything it would
just remain a big Mist if it could ever
coalesce into anything
so there's this notion of What's called
the anthropic I think it's called the
anthropic principle that we only think
of ourselves as the only universe that
is because the laws
are such that we can see ourselves right
but in the other universes no one could
become and if you were to go there you
would basically just explode you know
you would just dissipate into nothing
right right so so embedded in the laws
of the universe are the rules that allow
for evolution
right it doesn't mean that they were the
universe was created for that it's just
that retrospectively it is that
there's a science fiction book that I
always remember a story
um about this thing that evolved in an
ocean on another planet and it in the
and it began with it could not remember
but could deduce its Origins
right so we can't remember our Origins
but we can deduce them sure we can
deduce the kinds of things that must
have happened and then we can even go
beyond that now as I'm saying about the
structure of the universe to say that
the structure of the universe allows for
atoms it allows for molecules those
molecules can come together and if they
can reproduce they will that's the
essence of The Selfish Gene from Richard
Dawkins is that if given resources and
you can reproduce you will find a way to
reproduce
right so you don't need to imagine a god
right that created you right but you
know it's it and and he goes through a
lot of very good arguments about it but
but so that's the kind of way that I I
think of it that it says that if we came
from a panspermic event I'm not sure
that's a word but just made it up uh
then that means that there are other
potentially seated planets elsewhere
must also could have right you know
created civilizations
now and then if you go as far as saying
that
um there are other universes
exactly which have let's say different
timelines once you propose that Another
Universe can happen
and it might have a different timeline
than ours
it I mean it the time there's no such
thing as a common timeline at that point
you're independent you can come from any
point in another universe's timeline and
if you are sufficiently Advanced you
might have learned ways to jump between
universes
fascinating what what do you think is
the most likely
theory of the universe the Multiverse
simulation Theory holographic
you know I
I think the holographic and simulation
Theory I mean
I'm closer to the holographic idea
because we are a low dimensional
projection of something of a higher
Dimension we know that other dimensions
exist that doesn't mean other dimensions
meaning other realities it means that
the four dimensions that we think of are
a subset of something more complex
our understanding of how the physical
particles operate
uh in many of the theories requires
additional concepts of other dimensions
okay other things live there but maybe
they do I don't know but
um so is I'm more aligned with the
holographic notion the idea of a
simulation I mean uh
that implies I mean very often
what what that brings to mind is the
notion that somebody's sitting behind a
computer terminal somewhere running us
like a Sims game right um and you know
that's a little too simplistic obviously
but you know if you created the universe
with all of these rules like it looks
like a giant computer program which it
does fine call it a simulation I don't
care
you know I mean a simulation implies
that it's not real
I mean
that we exist only in somebody else's
computer
but that doesn't matter to me as far as
I'm concerned I'm real yeah it doesn't
change the way you live your life it's
still about me and unless they're going
to reach in and change the code halfway
through because they decide we're buggy
or we're caught in a loop you know okay
I mean looping is a thing I mean people
do Lube you loop on patterns with people
patterns with how you operate I mean
that does happen and I oh I do wonder if
there's that possibility where I was
just having this conversation the other
day that if we were to I don't know
shift Dimensions Ascend new Earth
whatever the concept or theory is would
you even know no I agree I mean I I was
thinking about something like this the
other day and I was watching some uh you
know History Channel or something just
flipping through late at night about
your reincarnation
reincarnations and
you know okay if if we reincarnate
infinitely in some ways it almost sounds
depressing
but like I'm kind of like I'm done how
many people say that right they're like
no no this is my last human trip promise
this is I'm done you know but if that's
just the way of things but if we get
erased each time well then it doesn't
matter it's not like Europe there's a
memory of all of the dramas that you
went on before
um so
you know I don't I'm not I I'm not quite
sure about what it is but I mean I'm
obviously the older you get the more you
start to think about what's what's next
I'm actually excited one way or the
other right I mean whether it's
you know death and it's the end well
okay who cares it's the end
uh or if it's some change
fine I'm ready for it I've said that um
I really want to figure out what the
truth and the nature of reality that's
my biggest question that I have in my
life is what is the true nature of this
reality that we live in and I said I'm
gonna have to die to find out I'm just
not ready you know like this this can be
really fun and really interesting here
in the meantime I mean I would hope and
this is perhaps narcissistic that having
achieved a level of self-introspection
uh about that that is an indication that
you're you know ready for a next level
all right that if you're oblivious to it
you're no different than
you know an animal
right I'm not disparaging animals but
you know that they're if they're not
conscious of it then you're not ready
for that next level
um I don't know well Consciousness you
said the word I mean such an interesting
Concept in theory and
so many people wondering about the
nature of it what are your thoughts on
it on because that that to me when I
think about the universe and I think
about patterns of things and
how it might all really be unfolding
there's this unique element of
consciousness of being aware of the
thoughts we're having being aware of
these things and it's like what is that
unique strain unique like
pathway of information that comes to us
um
that makes it feel less mechanical and
less like data it feels there's a feel
to it so what what are your thoughts on
on Consciousness at this point
well if you so if you are a brain
scientist you think that Consciousness
is just the pattern of electrical
signals between neurons
um
um maybe uh but if we go back to that
notion of there's like a a complex
structure to the universe of all of
these particles interacting Fields
Etc
um okay well
somehow whatever our Consciousness is
whether you're a materialist like a
neurosurgeon or you're uh you know
spiritualist
it doesn't matter your Consciousness
still sits somewhere in that space time
right it's just the the neural the
neurologist would think of it as your
brain organizes the space time to create
Consciousness it's still sitting in that
ether
right a spiritualist just says well
maybe it sits outside The Ether and
reaches in with like puppet strings and
manipulates the you know the the neurons
and that there's some interface that we
don't yet understand
which is sitting outside to influence
the materials in this universe so if
this would be a perfect example of where
does Consciousness sit well maybe
somewhere in those extra Dimensions or
at the very least it uses some of those
extra Dimensions yeah that's one way of
thinking about it you know I'm not again
I I'll say this and there's some idiot
on TWiT on Twitter who will pick apart
my words and make it sound like I said
something that I didn't right there's
one person in particular who's just
really annoying well they have a sad
life I don't know who they are but they
have a sad life
picking apart your brilliance
I find it exciting to think about I mean
they must be the most boring person at a
party Jason
um you know who I'm talking about I
won't say his last name
it but it it rhymes with Velveeta
called Velveeta
um so
you know it's uh
so
Consciousness then is something
interesting in that no matter how you
postulate it materialism or spiritual
it does sit in space-time somewhere now
the open question is is it independent
of the body
right does it you know once created
is it now a pattern uh-huh that can
exist forever
right
um and there's actually I've used this
example before one second I'm going to
step away and get the book
um
and I would recommend anybody who's
interested in it uh it's just a Treatise
you can download it off of the internet
um but he uh proposes of physics again
none of which I can truly understand but
you know it's yeah physicists argue with
each other all the time
what's the nature of the job of trying
to prove things out is arguing and so
what he basically says is that again
show this one picture
um that picture okay and it's a it's a
drawing of
um complexities of reality okay and
um how these complexities of reality as
organized by biological organisms can
create a structure our brain
that is sort of the birthplace of
Consciousness but the math says
at least in his view of the world the
math says that once created it doesn't
need the structure
anymore like a flower creates a seed the
seed doesn't require the flower anymore
the seed can go elsewhere
um you know it's a postulate sure it's
an interesting idea
um and it's backed by a lot of math
that the physicists will argue about
forever you know I see it at Stanford
all the time when the physicists and the
mathematicians get in a room together
with the computer scientists and you
know just
put them in a mud pit and let them have
fun right like to watch that let them
wrestle uh but uh you know I mean to me
that's an interesting idea
um that there is a physics support for
the notion that Consciousness can exist
independent of what created the
Consciousness in the first place yeah
that's fascinating
um so anyway that's just to me that's uh
that's exciting now whether that
Consciousness goes on to another place
and you know we can all read the books
about you know the Monroe Institute for
instance and uh you know this notion
that there's people have out of body
experiences and things have you ever had
one I had one that I was it was unlike
anything else okay
um would you be willing to share yeah
sure yeah I'm sure some pretty crazy
stuff no I remember uh waking up
and
um well I became conscious and I was in
the middle of nowhere like stars look I
kind of could see around and it was like
stars and I go oh my God I'm in space
all right oh my God how am I going to
get home
because I'm out here in the middle of
nowhere lost and then there was like one
star that was brighter than all of the
others
I said oh that must be
my star
and then suddenly I just felt this
rushing feeling
and I literally remember coming down
through the trees through the through
the roof and then into me and I woke up
no could be just a dream
but it's the most unusual dream that I
ever had
that had a sense of reality
I mean most readings I forget yeah well
that sounds like maybe like an astral
projection yeah which is yeah I mean I
don't know what it was but I found it
fascinating
you know and it resonated and you have a
story and you remember it and that's the
thing like you said about dreams you
normally forget so the fact that that
registered in your body and in your mind
in a different way
um is unique I think that those
experiences are what make us ask more
questions right so if we were to talk
about kind of back into like DNA a
little bit and
um
understanding that
I also am thinking about if energy can't
be create energy cannot be destroyed it
can only transform like what is that and
then I'm thinking a lot about like
quantum mechanics and quantum physics
and so like DNA if we're looking just at
us what is DNA and what because we have
this idea that DNA is our future right
like oh my mom had cancer so I'm going
to have cancer and it's just it's just
my map you know but explain what DNA
really is and how it works
oh wow okay
um so
well first of all it's an information
storage device
your dog wants to to he's got his looks
like he's got a rope or something he's
like I understood until this part and
now I don't get it
um
so it's an information storage device uh
it's a
um
it's a story in motion like I said
before it go you know you can trace it
back you know at least four billion and
perhaps more years and it's complexity
is increasing and at a certain level of
complexity let's say it instantiated the
ability to have Consciousness and to
perceive the universe
you know those all those space-time
particles actually
realizing that they are space-time
particles okay right wind waveforms
um but underneath that is an
architecture
and the architecture is in the DNA but
it's also in the proteins that are bound
to the DNA so we think of the genetic
code as this simple three-letter code
it's much more complicated than that
um and it's a dynamic computer that's
constantly sensing the environment and
changing accordingly
um and so you know it's just it
it's a Memory system
because embedded in the DNA is the is
the memory of how you evolved at least
it's the it's the solution to many
um
challenges
that the organism went through across
evolutionary time okay right in DNA yeah
it's embedded in there the solutions
right so the solution to breeding oxygen
which is otherwise dangerous to many
chemical reactions is to have
antioxidants is to use the oxygen to
power the body right so you know
the oxidative damage and oxygen will
create output of energy so what life did
was it realized well rather than let the
energy burn me I'll use it
for work
I'll I'll make it useful
so that's a solution so energy
metabolism is a solution to
you know the the poisoning that oxygen
can can do
to certain systems right
um
photosynthesis is a solution
to
the damage of photons
rather than letting them damage us we'll
use them to create matter
that's create matter but to basically
you know bring uh carbon dioxide and uh
um energy together and create
energy and oxygen but once it created
that then you have to find a way to deal
with the damage that oxygen can produce
and so you know so
each step of the way there were
additional solutions that needed to be
found through evolution
you also have to remember that for each
individual
um you have sort of a local memory
solution and in diversity
is uh is the solution for more potential
problems because you never know what the
next problem is going to be
so this notion that diversity in
genetics is important
uh is key I mean you know the the the
problem of the Potato Famine was you
know in Ireland back in the day was in
part a monoculture
uh of CR of potatoes that were being
used
um and that monoculture allowed for this
one fungus to spread across you know the
potato blight to spread across all of
Ireland and basically star people the
solution was going and finding other
potatoes uh back in the in the in the
new world that were resistant to it and
breeding those features in
we had the same problem in corn corn
blight right Etc these the the when you
lower diversity
basically you're lowering the number of
potential Solutions
uh and all it takes is one uh
ecologic change the introduction of a
fungus and wipe the whole thing out but
if you have diversity you know as A9
this is not a political discussion it's
it's but but the same thing is true
societally sure that a certain I mean
you don't want too much diversity
because that's chaos
right you know but you need a certain
amount of diversity to maintain the
potential for Solutions but that notion
is natural
right it's not a political argument it's
just a natural
world solution to uh to unexpected
futures
right the future is going to bring and
so you know if you all thought one way
then you might not have the solution and
the UAP phenomenon is exactly a case in
point if we all think that there's
absolutely no chance that uaps are a
non-human intelligence
then we'll forever just be looking at
these things moving in the sky and just
say well I don't know what they are so
therefore they don't exist right and so
when you have people like you and me and
others who are presumably listening to
this podcast many of whom would say well
I don't know what it is but I know that
it is
right exactly my Mantra is
knowing that it is is the same thing as
saying not saying that I believe it's
saying that I believe the data
right I don't believe in a conclusion I
know that the data is real
verify it to you know anybody's
satisfaction that the data is real how
to interpret it
is still an open question and and
luckily I've seen because I've been
pushing this a lot and a lot of people
you know I guess have heard me talk now
probably a few million
and
um
I I see thankfully these words being
repeated and refined
and used against the Skeptics
because I don't mind Skeptics as long as
they're not pathologically skeptical
right
skepticism is healthy it's asking
questions it's asking questions it's
peer review Etc but as long as it's not
I mean the problem is many of them
uh you know it's to them it's
disparaging they'll use and overuse the
term alien or little green man as a way
to degrade
uh those who are you know think more
open thinkers and to me that's just
that's just to me that's disqualifying
them as as reasonable Skeptics well I
feel like people that aren't open-minded
really
it's um you know there's a potential for
the fundamentals of life to be rocked
and when that happens it's just you know
a house of cards for everything and um
they cling really hard to the things
that they they know because it keeps
them safe
um to close the loop on the DNA thing
that I'm curious about is the elements
of epigenetics and how this connects
then maybe with those other dimensions
because
genetics
their epigenetics is the expression
which is at be around or is that right
so it's not the actual genetics it's
just the expression of the genetics that
you're activating so is there is could
that correlate then with these other
dimensions and this connectedness that
we have
yeah I mean another way to think about
epigenetics is at least the first level
of it is the proteins that are binding
to the DNA
so they're the first translators they're
the first interpreters of what's in the
DNA the DNA is a scaffold that the
proteins bind to because they recognize
a code and they bind to that and the
code tells protein one two and three to
bind here here and here and that allows
a machine to come together
because of proximity
um and then that machine is the is
interpret basically you can think of
that machine as interpreting the
underlying code
um and so as you build out further and
further levels of complexity because
this then builds neurons the neurons
will go here and there uh and then that
builds Consciousness and then
Consciousness somehow let's say is again
sitting in
space time I don't mean woo-woo I mean
it truly is you and I are just patterns
of space-time
um and then so yeah at the end of the
day the DNA is architecting
a structure that creates Consciousness
now it took
you know for at least four billion years
to happen
right for it to do that but deeney
doesn't care deeney doesn't think about
time Dean I only thinks about survival
right I mean the the rule of The Selfish
Gene hypothesis is survive
you know at all costs now you know from
a Consciousness standpoint
is at what point does Consciousness
intervene and say
is at all cost really the rule
right you know do I now intervene and
say okay well at all cost doesn't mean
me against you
right you know it means us
right and somehow us is uh what takes us
forward you know because the US
principle actually is a a greater form
of survival
right right it's a it's kind of a we if
it becomes like a tribe yeah exactly and
then when does the concept of a tribe
translate to a nation
to a people to
you know multiple peoples or multiple
things so you so I wonder sometimes when
let's say that these things that we're
seeing are real
um notice I use the word if still sure
um
you know let's say that they are doing
what they're doing and they're more
advanced
uh
clearly they're interested in us it is
interested in us whatever it is they're
not intervening not stomping on us
right if they wanted to stop on as
clearly they could all they would need
to go is out to the asteroid belt and
throw a big rock at us and that'd be the
end of us right I mean doesn't take much
effort you know musk could probably do
it if he got mad at Twitter for not
letting him buy them
um so uh you know it's like the ultimate
Bond movie
um and uh
so you know maybe their purpose is like
our Purpose with setting up national
parks or nature preserves in Africa and
South America they're basically they've
set us up as a nature preserve
yeah
I mean frankly I don't know why we're
bothering frankly going to Mars why
don't we just go you know 10 miles
underground and build out caverns and
put big lights up there's lots of energy
there's lots of geothermal energy down
there right I mean do you believe in a
hollow Earth theory or not but you know
if there's if there are bases here yeah
well they're clearly not on the surface
they're underground you know we see
things coming and going from the water
all the time great place to go
humans don't aren't bothering down here
you know they don't have the technology
to live down here but you don't have to
go far enough down
right to do things you know you could
you could hollow out caverns and live
underground and maybe maybe what we're
seeing is actually the diet you know
some dinosaurs that became sufficiently
intelligent and they basically said well
let's just get out of the way of all of
these climate changes and just go
underground because we're happier
underground than whatever
I don't know I mean you're just making
it up as I go there sure I mean there's
plenty of those theories out there
um about all of that stuff surface of
the point we're so freaking
eccentric
we think that the surface of the planet
is what everybody would want because we
want it exactly and then we look for us
out there in the universe too but what
if it's not us what if it's not just
like this because there are so many
brilliant people like yourself that talk
about how fickle it is to even exist
with slight changes in
oxygen and all kinds of Base elements
that we have we could be gone one big
solar flare is going to basically crush
the planet
because you know it'll knock out all our
electrical systems I mean they happen
all the time solar flares happen all the
time right yeah it just all it takes is
like one really bad one and it'll be
like an EMP pulse and that would be it
would knock out all of our electrical
systems
you know talk about a disaster
yeah so and maybe that's the reason why
they basically said well you know let's
just go under underground or we can tell
that there's going I mean a perfectly
good reason for doing something like
that would be you you look into the
nearby solar systems and you realize
that there's a star within a few hundred
light years it's about to go Nova yeah
and that the radiation front from that
Nova would basically wipe out
your civilization so how do you harden
it you go underground
once you're underground for a few
Generations you're like well why do I
need the surface I'm perfectly happy
down here
let's let the surface be as it is and
we'll go look at it like a park and
stroll around when we need to I don't
know I'm just again making it that's
Antarctica right yeah did you find any
any bases in Antarctica no I didn't find
any bases there I did read a book by
who's that guy Hancock uh Graham Graham
Hancock I don't know why I picked it up
and I'm on the way there it was all
about Antarctica and the original he
basically was saying you know Atlantis
was in Antarctica before some big Global
shift you know and and he writes a great
story I don't know how much of it is
true is it Fingerprints of the gods or
was it the next one no it was one um I I
don't know which one it was but it was
yeah the the one kind of salient point
that he continues to raise is that all
cultures have
um
a uh
um history of of a flood
and that
soon after the flood these people showed
up
um and interestingly and this is like
everywhere from South America to you
know uh Middle East Etc people who show
up
in the drawings and the carvings look
the same and of carrying like a purse
right oh yeah I've seen them I've been
to Egypt I've been to Chichen Itza I've
been to a bunch of ancient sites Peru
yeah there's all kinds of crazy symbols
where they look like they're holding a
bag a bag and so it's like that's
interesting you know again it's I don't
think it concludes anything but he
weaves a beautiful story right
um and so I was reading that on the way
across and while I was in Antarctica uh
so I know I didn't see anything I mean
the place was gorgeous really oh yeah
absolutely gorgeous yeah not just
flattened Barren no no no no especially
the peninsula there are rock formations
and things and we took a helicopter
around these towers of rock uh out in
the middle and I mean just otherworldly
truly and you were looking for uaps or
you were just no it had always been a a
bucket list kind of thing to do and so
we you know we went on this uh it was a
pretty high-end thing it had helicopters
in the submarine
on it so I spent a fortune on it but it
was worth it so cool I have so that
sounds fascinating I'm I'm very
interested in Antarctica myself
um you were talking about
um you know this sort of come together
all for one and the power of that and
then I can't help but think about Ai and
you know the future and the trajectory
of AI and that how that may affect us
and also whether or not that is the next
phase I mean if our Consciousness can be
put in a forever body of some sort then
is it really any different I mean we're
essentially being upgraded in a way or
is there something special and unique to
this biological human body that um we
essentially believe has you know not
um been made right well you know
can AI be conscious
in the same sense as I've just been
discussing it about some level of
complexity that instantiates something
independent
at least
you know probably not now right or not
in our or immediate future
can it replicate what we think is
consciousness
very likely I mean you already have seen
the arguments about Google right and
that thing that you know that program is
you know I don't think it's conscious
but you know it it was pretty remarkable
it was a far more interesting dinner
conversation than I've had with even
some of my professor friends from
Harvard and MIT
right I mean much more open and you know
interesting I would love to have someone
like that as a conversationalist
right so now where does the transition
happen for us
well again I mean
I I hate to boost his already immense
ego but not that he's listening to this
Elon Musk you know basically
I didn't say stole but borrowed the
concept of neural links from science
fiction this notion that you can
interface
and access compute abilities we do it
already I mean Wikipedia is like uh you
know I everybody's an expert if they can
type in the search terms and get a
Wikipedia concept imagine that being
instantly available to your head it's an
upgrade it's an upgrade imagine you know
something which is recording your every
moment so that when you say where are my
keys
the you know the the compute in your
head said I see I saw you leave it on
the table downstairs and it flashes that
image to you sure right that's coming
right it's coming one day and so
we've now transferred our memory much of
our capability of the memory to the
computer let's say in some near future
um it could record your life so now I
mean at 61 I can barely remember some of
my former dogs
you know I can remember them but I can't
remember the moment that I just had with
two of my dogs in bed this morning
petting them and you know loving them
um but maybe I could recreate that so
I've now transferred memory emotions
uh and the recreation of those memories
and moments to a computer
what's left
maybe just the decision processes but
then maybe we start to give the decision
processes over to the computer what
should I do today
well here's the most efficient way to to
do all the stuff that you're doing so we
become smaller and smaller and smaller
and what we've handed over to
an AI is larger
and so at what point do we decide
as humans
that we don't need that anymore because
most of what we are is now in the
computer I would say that we that
doesn't have a soul
at least if a soul is true but you know
maybe that's what we're seeing in these
uaps because it's a natural extension of
where we're going unless we create laws
that stop it from happening
or there's some sort of a program pogrom
uh or a crusade against them
it's coming
and so we will transfer ourselves over
and then unfortunately people like musk
would live forever
[Laughter]
fortunately people like you would yes
that's that's true yeah unless he turned
us on sir into slave robots but um
anyway computer the danger is control
all delete you know that's also also a
danger I mean I'm
believe me if Elon gets something that
uh or somebody else there's other people
as well just using him as an example
um get something that allows for memory
aids
I'll be all for it if it doesn't you
know if it doesn't like destroy my brain
in the process of upgrading you know and
then I can't upgrade further another
point I'll do I'll do it what about
intelligence upgrades oh sure and
increasing the data that you have on
board right so you're a fan of some of
the potential of neuralink yeah but I
mean you know you've heard me probably
talk about where does creativity and
insight come from and where are we
accessing these downloads that people
get
have you ever had that by the way oh my
God you work is it does it feel like
what I've I'm glad you said that because
it seems like a lot of really brilliant
people end up actually backing up into
an idea that they had originally and
then figuring out the essentially the
math to it and so what are what are some
of those there's many books written
about this and going back decades about
how people have realized that they just
get these ideas out of nowhere
I think that if we transfer ourselves to
AI we'd lose that yeah I'm implying that
there's some woo-woo associated with
where we get these ideas from
I mean let's not I won't parse words uh
you know you you could imagine into some
sort of subconscious process that truly
is just all mathematics or there's
something else going on because some of
the ideas that I've had came from
absolutely nowhere there's no way I
would have known what these things were
before I thought the idea
um so I was like okay well did somebody
give it to me or you know I don't like
to think that there's a guardian angel
or somebody out there who really cares
about me personally
um or is there something about the way
you structured the question
that and there's a saying come or if
there's a Zen or a Buddhist
um concept that the perfect question
is the flip side of the perfect answer
that if you structure the question in
just the right way the answer is obvious
right that the the the question almost
presupposes the answer
and so maybe if the physics of the
universe is some people say it's an
information physics
if the physics of the universe and it
can Traverse time let's say uh and let's
say that we don't understand enough
about the universe to say that it can't
um then if your brain puts together
a conscious structure
that is the question
it might be asking and you know might be
querying the universe for the answer so
it's your executive function of who we
think we truly are that organizes the
question in a way
uh in our brain that create creates the
query and it just takes time and the
right moment for all of that to have
come together to be quite the answer
comes and boom it gets downloaded
because it was already there yeah yeah
right it's not that anybody's giving it
to you
is you're giving it to you by creating
and again it's all postulates where does
it come from
what do you think speaking of questions
what do you think is the most important
question that humans can ask are we
alone that to me is the most important
question if we're not alone
then somebody else might have answers
to other let's say less
or more immediate existential
uh questions right that you know what
what can we do about this what can we do
about that or you know are there other
dimensions are there you know
you know what is you could list a
thousand questions and you know if they
would be willing to give us the answers
right and I
personally think that frankly we're not
I mean I've said this before I think
we're just a bunch of angry
um Angry Apes I don't think we're ready
for
uh some of the answers yet and you know
it's like you don't tell your children
certain things until they're mature
enough and we've pretty much proven that
we're still not mature enough yet
you know it's it's interesting
um that Evolution as I said before
doesn't care about time DNA doesn't care
about time
we're sort of the first
level of civilization that was achieved
out of competition
right the tribe that was more
competitive than the other and frankly
more aggressive
um and that frankly had you know
narcissistic Psychopathic leaders that
were willing to unite
a continent
you know at the expense of blood
uh we're the ones that succeeded but as
we're seeing played out in today's
politics without getting political
um that's not necessarily a survival
trait
for a species right it's short-term win
long-term loss long-term loss so is is
the long-term play for evolution the
creation of a certain level of
complexity that either realizes it needs
to get rid of that aggression or there
will be a collapse
uh arise collapse rise until the
genetics is selected for that
is an interesting study that was done
and I don't remember who did it and
whether it was validated or not but it
was shown that
um in women
after Wars
uh that there were it was more likely
for the women's boy children to be
homosexual
interesting okay why okay what and the
end of postulate was
uh that
they would be less aggressive
and so there's kind of an encoding in
the woman to fear of
a problem in terms of stress that okay
we need to lower the aggression in the
males because they're getting out of
control
okay now is there an it does this happen
there are certainly other cases showing
that the grandmother who is starved
has a baby and if it's a woman
is epigenetically programmed to have a
child
who is more likely to gain weight
so there's this it's an epigenetic
programming event you can you can
basically it's it you know there was a
big thing between
darwinians and lamarchians back in the
day Lamarck was a
um his idea was that a giraffe's neck
gets longer because it was reaching for
it and somehow that gets encoded into
the DNA sure
um and uh and so the uh
that was discounted for you know almost
100 or so years and yet now we find
these little subtle hints that affect
Lamarck wasn't entirely wrong
so you know and and aggression can be
moderated apparently I I don't know that
being gay is is the right answer but
maybe there are it doesn't need to be
gay you know just less aggressive
children sure right
um and or less likely to want to fight
over the females
sorry to bring all that in but it's you
know that's that's our history
um and so you know so there's a there's
sort of a self-regulating capacity uh in
human society that is at least
epigenetically flexible
um and that we you know if we if we
think of of us having an absolutely
determined outcome
it's not quite right because our genes
right epigenetically are listening to
the context
and so there's a little bit of
flexibility built in there and that just
makes sense from a you know to build
that in from an evolutionary standpoint
is to you know you remember you're
trying to build in
Solutions
um and if the solution is to be a little
bit more flexible to turn the meter up
or down a little bit you don't want it
hard coded
you know because hard coding of genes
takes a long time to evolve in but if
you can hard code in a rheostat
then
um that listens to the environment and
it mostly is going to come in through
the eggs and less likely to come in
through sperm because the eggs are more
complex uh you can basically say that
the woman as a sensor
is the one that provides the egg and the
ability for the next Generations at
least most immediate generations to be
modulated a little bit
I just find that fascinating anyway wow
if there was an if if we were to be able
to use extraterrestrial intelligence and
there was some communication had and we
were able to learn something as you said
they might have some solutions to our
problems what is the problem that you
think needs the solution right now I
think yeah I think aggression leads to
Greed
uh aggression leads to overuse of
resources polluting the planet
um I don't think you want to get rid of
aggression entirely because somewhere in
aggression is also motivation
right and you know I'm aggressive in my
lab work I want you know I I want my
people to to win an argument around some
science
uh so I think there's a little bit
that's that's good so I think that
somehow how do we how do we modulate
that to me that's the to me that's
almost the most important because it if
you take any one of our problems you can
trace them back
one of the roots at the very least is is
over aggression
um you know and and another would be you
know
energy
obviously where's the is there a better
way to create energy than burning up
something that lived 200 million years
ago well it seems like Nicola Tesla had
some answers right yeah there's a great
guy you know if anybody ever wants to
look it up there's a guy at the
University of uh Colorado Boulder uh
Garrett Modell m-o-d-d-e-l and uh he's
been looking into these devices uh and
he's a serious physicist he's not one of
these free energy you know nuts spinning
magnets and stuff
um obviously I've looked into all of
this
um so I'm a Nut too uh
he has
um what he claims is an ability to it
looks like
uh
suck the energy of space-time out
through a a an asymmetric Casimir cavity
you got to go look it up it's a the Zero
Point Energy field okay um and he seems
to be creating power out of nothing and
he's created he says thousands of
devices uh and
um you know because they're all
miniature yeah
and and and I just heard this the other
day
um he's given it to nist which is the
National Institute of Standards and
technology which is you know a
government organization that validates
all kinds of things they're the ones who
basically says this is how much water
weighs the you know these are kind of
the fundamental principles and he's
given these devices and and it's claimed
that they've reproduced the observation
that he's getting these minute amounts
of power basically out of space-time now
what everybody's trying to do is prove
or disprove whether that's an artifact
or not you know
Garrett
g-a-r-r-e-t
Modell m-o-d-d-e-l
and he got a patent on on this which is
unusual because a lot of these so-called
free energy devices they
um they don't allow for patents
because you know they people say they're
junk I don't know why they do that but I
mean
there is a blue jay
that sees himself in the windows
seriously and he keeps tapping on the
windows
hello hello
what visitor that is this is believing
that there is somehow a Consciousness
that can come through a bird and say
hello to you say hello exactly yeah they
um I looked it up apparently they are
it's males do it and there must be a a
female and uh fledglings nearby I do
have a a last question
um
is kind of a two-part is there
information technology and being
withheld from the general public about
extraterrestrial and
all things extraterrestrial and
if they were why would they do that do I
absolutely know for sure because I've
seen it no I do not know that
do I think that it's the case absolutely
yes
and I have good reason to say that uh
that I can't talk about but I have good
reason to say it
um so
my interest is obviously and I've said
this many times
um any involvement that I want to have
in this
will eventually or should eventually
lead to public disclosure right now
whether I'm allowed to do that should I
ever get involved or be allowed to be
involved nobody's asked me so I'm not
you know
um that would be my goal because I think
there's a virtuous cycle that can occur
by letting the public in because if
there is anything to have been learned
they haven't learned much in the last 60
years
and
um or at least if they're letting it out
they're letting it out so slowly as to
be imperceptible to the public
um but what I also know is that anything
that is kept in silos which internal
special access programs are inevitably
kept as silos there's no ability to move
forward quickly you know I mean I just
know this in my lab if I if if person X
doesn't talk to person why they're both
just you know they each have a piece
that the other needs to create the
solution
um and so I think the question is how do
you manage a let's call it a a public
government slash private
um collaboration
that keeps the needs of everybody happy
where you know where the government is
basically holding right now all the
cards and
probably a few aerospace companies but
not the aerospace companies at large
basically small programs within them and
if you started to understand how the
government funds these programs you
understand how quickly things can go
south and become you know become uh
disconnected
from the original funding right keep
them separate they keep them separate
yeah
so I mean to me you know and whether you
know there's somebody sitting in an
office laugh listening to us laughing
saying yeah well they're never gonna
know forget them they can talk all they
want
um fine
when you have to tap into the quantum
and get the information yeah tap into
something Beyond but I mean
um I mean I think that's what
I mean so the short answer is I think
yes yeah but even I'm not satisfied that
the proof is there because
I still have the standards of science
that I want to apply to that which means
there needs to be reproducibility I
don't want somebody's to stand on a
lectern and tell me that it is you know
I I want to see it but I also don't want
to give the government permission
to tell me to
be interested in something or to believe
something or not I don't need
their permission
you know I don't need them to announce
it a lot of people do but I don't need
them to announce it I mean as you know
I've seen stuff I mean I I saw a craft
when I was a kid end of story it was 30
feet away
12 12-ish I can't remember when I was
when I was a paper boy I was a paper boy
for like four or five years
um
so I know I saw something
and I know it wasn't human
right so okay
but I that's anecdote to the rest of the
world
so we had this stuff why what would be
the what would be the highest potential
reason why information would be withheld
from all of us
well I mean people have talked about you
know Mass hysteria
Etc
um maybe there's something about them
that's really scary
you know that uh you know that to know
that we are somebody else's property
or you know I mean having helped that
maybe were farmed for something
you know uh that would be awful that
would be icky uh I mean it isn't as if
we don't Farm things but just to know
that you're not the top of the food
chain uh might not be a pleasant thing
but you know again it's about what
information do you give
to species like us that they wouldn't
kill themselves with
right I mean if you give people access
to free energy is is you know even a
small amount of free energy only a step
away to too much energy that you
basically blow up the planet
literally you know I mean the amount of
energy sitting in one cubic centimeter
of space-time is enough to wreak havoc
on the whole planet I mean it's just but
it's all tightly Bound in space is that
called Dark Energy no it's a zero point
field the Zero Point Energy field
um uh I mean Dark Energy might be part
of that I don't know good question
actually
um but anyway I mean just what we
understand about the zero point field
where particles appear and disappeared
sort of like I I think of it and a
physicist might yell at me for saying
this I think of it as the pressure in
the balloon that keeps the universe
expanding okay oh yeah yeah sure because
it's constantly expanding it's
constantly there and it's it's that
energy but it and this is what that guy
Garrett medell and everybody's been
claiming that maybe it could happen but
there are these Notions of the you know
the laws of thermodynamics that say it
can't well it's interesting that luckily
even physicists call them laws
sure people can change laws
yeah it's true you know maybe it's just
a law because it's just it just it it
maybe it's a law because it works within
our framework
maybe our framework changes so many
thought-provoking things
um thank you for sharing
such great introspection and really just
philosophizing and you know
contemplating all of the potentialities
out there and I have no doubt that
between you and your lab and all of
those that are working on these working
on these um questions that will continue
to find them in our lifetime maybe not
all of them right maybe we have to die
for that but definitely but there's a
really good thing that I'm seeing maybe
this is a good message to end on is that
the circle of individuals who's willing
to talk about this stuff openly has
dramatically expanded
the scientific colleagues that I have I
mean I was just at two meetings in the
last couple of weeks who walk up to me
and out of the blue say Gary
I've heard about all this stuff going on
and I know that you're interested in it
it's amazing can you tell me more
those same colleagues three years ago
their eyes would have glazed over or
they would have dismissed it so you know
I think there has been a sea change and
I I find that helpful
absolutely and then thanks for being
brave enough to uh go ahead and step
outside the box and be willing to talk
about it with me and other people and
just within your work uh it's really
cool and we're gonna we're gonna get
answers because of people like you great
well thank you so much you're welcome
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button